finally tonight another one of our own
from las vegas will be trying her luck
on jeopardy this week
we got to know local contestant jen
spinos from her first audition
to now joining alex on stage
over the summer 8 news now went behind
the scenes with jeopardy in their
virtual search for las vegas contestants
following locals as they navigated the
thorough process of
auditions interviews and mock games
welcome everybody
welcome to jeopardy this is your last
your audition
process one contestant we featured
trying out
jen spinos made it all the way through
jen
what is bailiff you're right she is now
ready to join alex
on the big stage in culver city for the
real deal no more zoom
an actual game of jeopardy i have to say
like
i think i'm going to cry when he steps
out on the stage it's
it's an amazing amazing opportunity to
meet him
jen is a loyal and long time fan of the
show and has been a nightly
jeopardy viewer for years i watch
jeopardy on eight news now
every single night and when i'm not
there i record it so i can watch it
later
she tells us she has put in the time
practicing and preparing for this
opportunity
when i found out that i was going to be
on the show
i did the best that i could i listened
to some some trivia quizzes and
did some studying and if alex asked her
what she loves about las vegas
first of all i love the people like i'm
a teacher and i interact with
the families in my in my neighborhood
and
um they're spectacular they're
giving kind people who want the best for
their children
there's mount charleston and red rock
and
it's it's actually quite beautiful
spoken like a true las vegas
good luck jen and we know jen is
watching right now because we just
emailed a little while ago as we're
wishing her good luck so hi jen
to you and your friends that are
watching eight news now and in just a
couple minutes all of us can watch her
on jeopardy at 7 pm